they're going house to house
and this is dangerous work not just for
soldiers
this child was caught in the crossfire
when police raided a suspected bomb
factory in eastern sri lanka
15 people died in the fierce gunfight
that followed
three of those were suspected suicide
bombers but
among the dead were six children this
one escaped alive
this won't stop so we won't stop either
we are the army
we are the people who protect the
country we will completely remove these
groups
right now for the authorities security
seems more important than accountability
yesterday this muslim family's home was
raided
around 15 percent or more than 15
percent
came with the vehicle they fully covered
themselves
only eye is visible they
all of a sudden they jump out everywhere
and in the top in the fence and
all surrounded us and
four or five people entered possibly
one of the person got my elder son
if he is connected to this incident
he also should be punished doesn't
matter but only my feeling is
who has taken that we don't know whether
these
security forces or somebody else we
don't know
it's a worrying echo of the bad old days
and
ways of the civil war when people simply
disappeared
one of the country's senior muslim
politicians sees the danger of such
fractures
we can't blame anyone we have to
unite president prime minister ministers
the government opposition or religious
leaders and people of sri lanka
we unite this cctv footage
shows the moment when one of the suicide
bombers entered the restaurant of the
kingsbury hotel in colombo
a quiet breakfast turned to terror and
only one of multiple
attacks around the same time
not far away a bomb exploded here in
saint anthony's shrine
last night we went inside there were
pools of blood on the floor
today those floors were sprayed with
water as the cleanup operation began
the cleanup workers have been drafted in
from the navy there are a lot of them
they're going back in now
after a break it's clearly very hard
work
nearly a week since the attacks it
should be a symbol of recovery and
rebuilding
but right now sri lanka simply does not
have that freedom
tom cheshire sky news colombo